- [Voiceover] In the figure
at left, I put, pasted it
up here, point O
is the center of a circle of radius 1.5.
We see that right over there.
The missing sector of the
circle has central angle AOB
equal to 2pi over 3 radians,
that's this right over here,
and that's the central
angle for the missing,
for the missing sector, right over there.
What is the length of arc ACB?
Now ACB, ACB is this arc.
It's kind of the rest of the circle,
the part that's not missing.
So, this is ACB right over here.
Well, the way that I would tackle this,
I would think, well,
what's the circumference
of the entire circle, and then
what fraction of the entire
circle is this arc length?
So, let's first think
about the circumference
of the entire circle.
Circumference is equal to 2 pi times r
In this case, our r, our radius, is 1.5.
So, it's gonna be 2 pi times 1.5.
Now, 2 times 1.5 is 3.
And so, this is going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal to 3 pi.
So, the circumference of
the entire circle is 3 pi,
and now there's a couple
of ways you could do it.
You could figure out, well,
what is the length of this arc
right over here and then subtract that
from the circumference and
then you'd be left with
the magenta part, or we could figure out
the central angle of the magenta part.
We could figure out this
angle, and think about
well, what fraction is
that going to be of the,
if we were to go all the way around,
and if we're thinking in
radians, going all the way around
is 2 pi radians.
So, what fraction is this angle of 2 pi,
and then that's going
to be the same fraction
that this arc length is of
the entire circumference.
Well, what's this angle going to be?
Well, it's going to
be, if we want remember
all the way around, if we
went all the way around
the circle, if we went all
the way around the circle
that'd be 2 pi radians.
But, if we wanna figure out
this magenta central angle
it's going to be 2 pi minus this
2 pi over 3.
So, this is going to be 2 pi,
let me do it in that magenta color.
So, the central angle for
this piece of the circle
for that's kinda the central angle for ACB
is going to be 2 pi
- 2 pi over 3.
I'm going all the way around,
but then I'm subtracting
out this part right over here.
Now, what's 2 pi minus 2 pi over 3?
Let's see I can find a common denominator,
instead of writing it as
2 pi I can write that as
6 pi over 3, so let me do that.
It's gonna be 6 pi over 3
minus 2 pi over 3.
Well, that's going to be 4 pi over 3
So, once again, this angle right over here
is 4pi over 3.
4 pi over 3 radians.
Now, what fraction is
that of if we were to go
all the way around the circle?
Well, once again, this
central angle is 4 pi over 3.
If you were to go all
the way around the circle
that's 2 pi.
So, this is the fraction
of the entire circle
that this arc represents.
And so, let's just multiply that times
the entire circumference.
Times 3 pi, and let's try to simplify it.
Let's see we have pi divided by pi,
and let's see if we take
this 3 and multiply it times
the numerator this three is
going to cancel that three.
And, we're gonna be left with 4 pi
over 2, 4 pi divided by 2
is equal to 2 pi.
So, that's the length, that's the length
of this arc.
So, it actually exactly 2/3
of the entire circumference.
So, let me just select that 2 pi.
And, we're done.